but as far as like updating the software
and stuff I think I'll be happy in in
five or 10 years that like changes that
I've made because of this
experience um have helped me like grow
as a person grow you know [__] dude
you're
[__] it's a it is a high road
attitude um to hear from you for me like
I can't I can't go any other road
because it'll just it's poisonous yeah
um what's next then what's next how do
we get to see you cuz I want to see you
go for that second S Young I'm gonna be
really really honest with you yeah I'd
love to I mean that's the goal like I'd
like to play uh in MLB um you know
looking for looking for a contract
and um yeah I mean I still I've been
training the whole time like we talked
earlier about how baseball's like my
backdrop like when things go bad I go
back to this and this has been one of
the most difficult things is like like
when baseball's taken away like what do
I fall back on so I just fell back on
training so I'm in you know I I've
improved like since last people last saw
me like I I'm throwing harder I've
developed new pitches my commands better
I'm still one of the best pitchers in
the world um I'd love to prove that
obviously I realize there's a lot of uh
you know other considerations besides
just Talent um at this point so I'm
hopeful that I get a job and I get an
opportunity to go out and and prove that
I'm good and I have a lot to offer I
think I got lot to offer the baseball
Community as a whole with content
entertainment and and all that I have a
lot to offer a team like one of the
things I'm really passionate about is
helping young baseball players have
their journey be easier than mine so we
actually train I think we got like 20
guys that we train for free at my
facility in in Arizona in the offseason
Pro guys that come in I've been working
with all the pitchers there and
developing pitches and Feud and mindset
and all that stuff I love that stuff so
I have a lot to offer from that
perspective I think to a team and a
clubhouse that I'm with um obviously
like performance like you got to win
games I know I can do that that's not
even a question in my mind so what was
like the financial because you were
making good money yeah right yeah I
signed um so I won the sa young 2020 and
then that was your contract year I was a
free agent after that yeah wow bro that
is a dream
and look I love it when dudes get paid
that's what George KD told me he goes
everybody's happy when somebody gets
paid man yeah so you had three years 102
million yeah so that it was a kind of a
unique structure the plan I had opt outs
after every year the plan was always to
the first play the first two years and
then opt out and be a free agent after
the third and I would have been two
years for 85 million the way the
contract worked out so an average value
of 42 and a. half million a year wow um
which was the highest annual average
value at that time for any baseball
player I think sh just crushed no way
you were like the top of the heat yeah
wow and did they still have to pay you a
certain amount of that yeah um I got
some of it I also lost some of it in the
you know I think
um I don't remember exactly what the
numbers shook out to be but I lost a
significant amount of it with the
suspension and stuff like that so and
was it expensive like the law attorney
fees and all that yeah man lawyers are
uh
very much needed like very specialized
and like you know you need you need them
but um very expensive yeah so it's
been um obviously baseball's given me a
lot financially um I'm doing fine I
don't want to come off like I'm you know
not F but uh it's been a heavy a heavy
hit for sure um and how do your agents
like do you try to go back at the same
rate like how does that even work is
that fair to ask you about ask you about
yeah yeah that's fine
um I don't like I just want to play like
that's that's where I'm at um like I
I'll play for league minimum and like
earn my money based in incentives like I
I don't care whatever whatever the
structure for the team is like that
makes them most comfortable like I it's
fine with me I just want to go play yeah
you know yeah incentive based right yeah
you want to you I'll show you if yeah if
you sign me and like not going right and
you don't like the reaction or you don't
whatever like you can cut me and then
you don't have to bear the um you know
the brunt of signing this let's say it's
a $10 million contract and you know
something's not going right and you
still have to pay the 10 million I don't
I don't need that like I just want I
want a job I want to go play and let me
just prove that I'm still one of the
best pitchers let me prove that I have a
lot to offer the organization yeah and
then I'll get paid in incentives I'll
earn based on what I perform I'm happy
with that um I've
never like I've always wanted to be that
way too like it's I've I've only wanted
to sign onee contracts because I never
want to be the guy that signs a
long-term deal and then is like okay
well I'm getting paid regardless so
performance doesn't matter and I'm just
going to like play out my years or
whatever I'm just going to get massages
or whatever paint my nails or whatever
yeah like shout out to the guys that
paint their nails no problem with it but
like yeah no judgment yeah but uh like
I I'm an intense competitor and I just
want to go compete and like I would like
to be compensated fairly for what I
produce so if I produce nothing I don't
feel like I should be compensated
anything if I'm the best pitcher in the
league I feel like I should be
compensated for being the best pitcher
in the league and the easiest way to do
that is just like minimum risk for the
team I'll play for the minimum and then
if I pitch really well then have
incentives that reward me for pitching
really well and the value that I give to
the team is equally shared and both
sides feel like they won um wow I'm I'm
happy to have any sort of
like like I want to work together with
the team I want to be a positive in the
community in the clubhouse on the field
like overall for the game of baseball um
I know that I can be that I have no
questions about it which is why I have
no problem taking like a incentive based
contract because I know that I can go
out there and deliver um I know the type
of person that I am I know the type of
results that I'm be able to produce and
I'm willing to bet on myself in that way
but at the at the end of the day like I
just I just want to compete like I just
want a chance to go compete and like do
the thing that I've spent 30 years
becoming one of the best in the world at
and the thing that I love to do um bro I
would if I had a team if I had even if
we had a spot here I'd hire you right
now I'd hire you to pitch what would you
what would you call what's your what'
your team name be oh that's a great
question huh put you on the
spot what's a good team name probably
maybe uh the Reverb or the lisps the
lisps yeah yeah dude there's so many
team how many teams are there you could
play for so many teams yeah we got 30 30
teams out there um bro some of them are
bad dude they need you I'm not I mean
some of these teams are ding bad or they
could be doing they could you could
maybe help yeah I think I could I mean I
don't think there's a team out there
that I wouldn't help in some way right
um but I also you know seeing the other
side of things like there's a lot of uh
you know potential uh distractions PR
concerns um I don't think they're I
don't think they would be as much as
people think they would be I think it'd
be like a couple days story and then
it'd be gone personally I I could be
wrong but um You' think there would be
some Publications out there that would
feel like hey the best the least
a way that we could be supportive after
you know maybe leading the charge with
not being as supportive but kind trying
to even the score you know yeah but I
don't know that's my thoughts yeah I
mean it'd be nice of course but um I'm
not
gonna it's out of your control yeah if
it happens it happens like mooki coming
out and saying some stuff publicly was
like a I would never ask him to do that
but it was
so like it meant a lot to me mook's my
guy I love that guy mainly like I just I
just want to I want to play man I
haven't I I miss competing I'm yeah was
it tough to was there certain parts of
the Season that are tougher to watch
like when it gets in the playoffs or
it's all just kind of tough it's been
tough to watch baseball um because like
I know I'm good enough to be out there
and I I want to be out there and I
haven't I haven't had the opportunity to
to be out there um when I was in Japan
last year I watched a lot of games
because I was like okay I'm I'm here I'm
playing I'm like in it I can respect
what the other people are doing I can
learn from it I'm like figuring things
out and that was nice to have some of
that back I just
haven't I don't think it's been healthy
for me to like consume MLB content the
last couple years um which is sad
because like everything that I've tried
to build is like grow that entity and
like help right build it and then um I'm
still involved in in doing that I'm
still but I'm just pursuing a slightly
different way where I'm not even like
I'm not really watching games and um I'd
like to get back to a place where like I
can like watch and like be interested in
like appreciate the great things that
other people in the league are doing I
just had to like be a little bit
protective of my of my uh Mental Health
on on that front but yeah because would
it just kind of it would just break your
heart probably yeah it was tough man
like seeing what other guys are doing
and not being able to be happy for them
feeling that resentment of like well I
should be out there being able to
compete too God um I don't like I
never I don't you should have been
there's no reason yeah I can't even
imagine I don't like being negative
towards other people and like feeling
envious of other people's
accomplishments I like to look at things
and be like wow this person is really
really good and I can appreciate it
because I do it in all other sports like
I watch Brady play and I'm like I'm
going to watch as much of this as
possible because he's going to be gone
at some point and like you got to
appreciate what's what this is yeah same
with
SV yeah um and and momes right now Clark
I do that with and caylin Clark I want
me and cayb Presley want to come to your
um game at again uh so if we if he can
help us sorry I just had to say that out
loud dude love it Mist Pete that's what
I call it she's a I love watching her um
but yeah man yeah it's I think because
if you if there was no there was no
criminal wrongdoing there was nothing
wrong yeah there was nothing wrong yeah
um you can find things that if you look
at yourself yes I could adjust some of
these behaviors and stuff but as a human
being behaving in the world to not have
done anything wrong yeah and to have
it's really just a trial that you've
been through it's almost like a [__]
Scarlet Letter you know it was like a
Scarlet Letter in a way you know yeah
you get branded with something and then
you carry it I'll carry it the rest of
my life like I'll always be known for
this in some way and hopefully over time
it'll be less and I'll the positive
things that I do will get more attention
and be more synonymous with my brand but
like this will always be there um which
is which is tough it's tough to I can't
even imagine I can't think about it too
much you know yeah yeah because it's
just such a it's such an anomaly yeah
you know um but God dude
that yeah we just got to see you back
out there there's no valid reason why
you shouldn't be back out there yeah I
appreciate you saying that like I
there's no valid it doesn't even make
nothing I if the universe doesn't make
this happen it doesn't even make any
sense anymore yeah yeah I uh I'm hopeful
that it will I'm hopeful it will I I
just I'd like to entertain people I'd
like to to pitch I'd like to win when
does spring training start uh usually
like second week around Valentine's Day
second week February some teams are like
February 12th some teams are like
February 16th it's like they all kind of
report at different dates but yeah
middle of February wo date with the
diamond huh yeah and that's not Dustin
pory I'm talking about uh baseball
diamond yeah yeah we could see it
bro